[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
it was not a showdown but rather an
exercise in placing markers the russia
us talks in geneva settled basically
nothing however the biden administration
can no longer say it does not understand
russia's position on pan-european
security the ball is in washington's
court
[Music]
to discuss these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest
glenn diesen in oslo he is the professor
at the university of southeastern norway
as well as author of the book great
power politics in the fourth industrial
revolution and in budapest we have
george samueli he is a podcaster at the
goggle which can be found on youtube and
locals all right gentlemen crosstalk
rules and effect that means you can jump
in anytime you want and i always
appreciate it okay let's go to glenn
first um
glenn you know we we've had about two
weeks of meetings a different
formats um essentially on the same topic
at least from the russian perspective
and trying to
get um nato um on the same page to talk
about pan-european security i i watched
the pressers lavrov and lincoln lincoln
has moved a little bit in the right
direction but not very far in my opinion
like as i said in my introduction
basically nothing has been done but i
think it's also fair to say that
washington can't say it doesn't know
what putin wants as they love to say
your assessment go ahead
no i agree and i think the way the
meeting began kind of demonstrated uh
well how far apart they were and not
even discussing the same theme because
when
moscow met with washington day the the
main discussion well the americans came
prepared to speak about ukraine uh and
effectively for for the russians they
said no well ukraine is a symptom of a
broader problem we've had for the past
30 years which is there is no
pan-european securities system and there
are no pan-european security agreements
anymore that works so
so they want to highlight this principle
that well this main main tension which
is you know we have two different
principles in europe the russians are
saying the foundations of pan-european
security has to be one side does not
expand its security at the expense of
the other so indivisible security and
the americans say no no european
security is based on the right of nato
to expand and uh you know if russia
infringes on this then this is an attack
on you know democracy and freedom and
you know this is the the usual slogans
so so so this is kind of where where
they started off and took a while to
even move away from simply talking about
russian troops on russian soil in in
you know
in the proximity of ukrainian borders to
actually discuss european security uh
agreements and uh again
it hasn't been successful because there
are no there's not been no interest in
making any compromises or you know
attempting to meet anywhere in the
middle or you know at least they're
starting to have some understanding of
what bothers russia but again so far the
americans have limited the response to
stating to looking for ways of punishing
russia and forcing it to do as they're
told effectively and uh this is why the
last meeting between lavrov and blinken
was a little bit awkward because you
know lincoln obviously came prepared to
say here we are we're united west we're
not going to give you anything now you
do as we're as you're told otherwise you
know you're going to have all this
sanction all this punishment however
he showed up with realizing that the
continental europeans at least are not
with him on this one the british might
be but
but the europeans are not and so he
didn't really have that much to to
present and this is why
uh they don't know what to do now
because again this was the whole
approach of the unipolar air we could
ignore russia because
all the power was in the west but now of
course the problem is russia is not
afraid of any sanctions and more
diversified it has the military
advantage along its own borders it's
effectively saying listen we have
security
concerns if those are not respected we
have to act on them let's have proper
agreements where both securities are
taken into account and you know slow
steady but slowly blinking's kind of
realizing
they can't dictate what the outcome will
be here so they have to find some
compromise and this is where painful
position the americans are in because
they've been able to
you know simply dictate and demand
unilateral concessions for 30 years and
you know it's coming to an end so it
doesn't surprise me that this is a
difficult pill to swallow for washington
yeah george i'm calling this program
lincoln's cosplay because that's exactly
what it was um yeah i want to reiterate
a point that glenn made because i think
it's very important for our audience
because of the very distorted narrative
that's going on right now
russia wants to have good relations with
its neighbor ukraine it doesn't want it
to be a hostile country and most
importantly it doesn't want nato in
ukraine it's not about ukraine it's all
about nato expansion and it is so
irritating it makes us all pull our hair
out is that the this very stilted
narrative that is being uh presented to
publics around the world go ahead george
that's exactly right and um that's why
it's hard to see whether any real uh
compromise is possible so um over the
weekend we had the united uk
foreign office issue this extraordinary
statement saying that um
they've uncovered a plot to over but on
the part of the russians to overthrow
the government in kiev and to put in uh
their people in place and
you know that's that's it and then the
the americans immediately said yep yeah
we agree that's our finding too so
you know they they're now
not only insisting that it's all about
ukraine not about uh just the
russian security concerns about uh
building a security architecture in
europe it is all about ukraine and that
at any moment uh russia will invade or
uh you know put it you know organize a
coup and install some obscure person uh
in charge in ikea so and and then even
last week we had the uh the day before
uh lincoln's meeting with lavrov the
state department issued these two
extraordinarily
intuitive statements about uh russian
lies and disinformation so
this is really the problem that as far
as the western and by western radio i
mean the u.s and the uk
uh ministers are concerned that it is
all about uh russia trying to uh invade
uh threaten uh take over uh ukraine
and
[Music]
they pretend not to understand what uh
russia
is talking about them and i think it's
uh it does come to a very dangerous
situation because
[Music]
now
i think we're
heading towards
possibly a crisis during the uh the
beijing olympics if
uh the uh government in kiev tries to
stage some kind of a provocative
incident and which might uh trigger a
russian intervention um that that i mean
russians obviously say russians
obviously do not want anything like that
but it's it's it's a possibility and
given the way the the uh the british and
the americans are presented and they'll
say oh well that's it that's what we
were saying you know russia is just in
the business of uh invading ukraine
you know glenn i'm glad that george
brought up those two state department
reports on disinformation and
misinformation whatever it was um
because it seems to me that the u.s
state department is actually trying to
corral nato members because they see
that it's praying okay we we had um last
week we had
the uk sending weapons to ukraine and
they avoided german air space because
the germans don't want to set they think
this is provocative here and then we
have we have president macron head of
the president of the rotating your eu
presidency and you know he's come out
with you know uh statements about um
respecting security of all countries and
very nervous about provocations it seems
to me that state department is is trying
to it's spending actually more time
trying to keep nato in line than it is
actually um and having a dialogue with
russia because if that's a dialogue
that's a dialogue of the deaf and dumb
glenn
yeah well that was the arguments coming
out of britain as well that uh when they
were making the arguments that we
shouldn't you know buy into the russian
narrative they were specifically
referring to the europeans that they are
starting to repeat the russian
propaganda but again propaganda's very
misused word in all this i mean with
propaganda you have the intentional
framing of any conflict and a very
common technique for example is to use
very simple binary framing and this is
what nato propaganda is which is
suggesting the only solutions to this is
either we have nato expansion or we have
a russian sphere of influence in ukraine
and this and you know so we have to
choose these are the two this is how
propagandists work and and this is and
it's so ridiculous which is why
a lot of these discussions have been
very dishonest because they're mostly
comprised of slogans aimed towards an
uninformed public rather than making any
common sense i mean surely there are a
third option here russia's not have
doesn't have the capabilities or
intentions to have some
exclusive influence in ukraine uh but
but these are the only options either
military alliance towards russian
borders or russia takes over ukraine
surely the whole point of security
agreements is to find these middle
points for example a neutral ukraine
which russia's always been happy with
but again it's this very dishonest
statement same as um you know the
secretary general nato uh stoltenberg he
was saying russia doesn't have any
legitimate reasons to be afraid of nato
because we're a defensive alliance
i mean really is still
i remember already in 1999 henry
kissinger was saying well we can't say
that nato is defensive anymore to the
russians now that we're bombing the
serbs and also later going after the
libyans i mean this you can try to
justify these wars in any way you want
this illegals were but illegal wars by
the way but they're not defensive and so
so just call it a defensive alliance
it doesn't make any sense also
um also that
only recently there are senior officials
of the obama administration farkas i
think her name is argued that russia now
that u.s should actually go to war
against russia not just over ukraine but
you know take back crimea push russia
out of south ossetia
so you can't have it both ways you can't
say that russia
nato in the future can be no threat to
russia and at the same time argue that
uh um
argue that we should use force against
them also this idea that russia should
have no veto this is also you know we
say it over and over again as if it
makes any sense i mean if nato is going
to monopolize on security in
europe that and the biggest country in
europe should not have any say over it i
mean this is an absurd statement
obviously russia will have a veto either
it has it within institutions or it will
have to rely on its own on its military
in order to uphold that veto which is
now expressed as a red line so nothing
makes any sense and then just the last
one is the nato secretary general
explicitly saying nato does not
discriminate against new and old members
well this was the whole point of the
nato russia founding act of 1997 this
very explicit promised committee not to
putting nato to permanent troops in
eastern europe and now they're saying no
no this goes against our principle well
you can't do it both ways you can't sign
an agreement you know only pan-european
security won't put troops there and then
say no well this goes against our
principles so we can't follow
the agreements we signed under so it's
very it's very strange discussions and
and uh so i think it's good to get for
russia to get some of this out in the
front because this
it to me it doesn't
make any in any sense at
know you and i have often reflected that
you know essentially nato is just a
propaganda machine okay because that's
what it
invests a lot of money in and and as
glenn is rightly pointed out it just
creates all these false binaries okay
and
um in my mind that's intentional because
they have no intention of recognizing
russia's um national security interests
20 seconds before we go to the break
george go ahead yes no
as uh glenn pointed out i mean it's they
are
expansionist as which means that by
definition they are not defensive i mean
defensive means you stay in place and
defend what you have uh they have been
expanding and they insist on their right
to uh continue to expand and uh and when
it says quite explicitly in that 1997
agreement which is no permanent uh
forces uh stationed uh
in the in the former uh countries of the
warsaw pact and then when the russians
point this out to them hey we you know
we have an unconditional right to do
whatever we want right
hold that thought jordan we're going to
go to a break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on some
real news stay with us
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
this is the home edition to remind you
we're discussing real news
[Music]
okay let's return to george here george
you want to talk about the presser
and it wasn't jointly held okay in
geneva which you know says something and
i thought it was very interesting that
um um you know
russia says that um the us will respond
to russia's written proposals next week
that's how the the russians interpret it
and here okay lavrov and lincoln they
were heading two different delegations
and it was shortly after they were
talking but lincoln he told the press uh
corps something very different um
is it bad memory or just will willful um
not understanding he said
the us
hoped to share
its concerns and ideas
in more detail in writing next week
those are two very different things
these two men just had spoken to each
other and it doesn't say any kind of
explicit
reaction to two written documents that
the russians propose to the united
states and to nato separately and before
as i end my question here george again
we have out of washington saying that
they want to have this as secret
diplomacy russia is
uh committed
in this process to public diplomacy
thoughts
yes yeah and i think that's a very good
point um
i i do not think that the americans are
going to respond uh to the uh russian
documents i think that uh to the extent
that they will uh present a written
response i think it will be a familiar
litany of complaints about the russians
oh the you know crimea
uh
the the donbass the skripals navalny uh
interfering in our elections brexit and
whatever it's just gonna be the usual uh
uh complaints i do not think that they
they intend to address any of these
issues because they don't acknowledge
the legitimacy of these issues and that
is why
the situation is dangerous because i
think the russians will feel that the
only way um our concerns will be
addressed and that the seriousness with
which we're uh coming to this will be
addressed
is if you know in the event of some kind
of military action because uh otherwise
they're just going to keep talking about
you know pointless things like well arms
control uh transparency
uh you know mutual confidence building
measures with you know military
exercises stuff that they've been
talking about for decades but this isn't
really what the uh the russians are
after and and really one has to say that
the framework of of some kind of a
security agreement shouldn't be that
hard to find which is no nato expansion
in return russia also commits not to
bring in any states into the uh
collective security treaty organization
and say okay so
for everyone else neutrality and there's
nothing wrong with neutrality no one's
interfering in your domestic affairs it
just means that
you're not uh joining any uh military
alliance i mean we used to have during
the cold war the non-aligned movement a
gigantic movement of states that were
very happy simply to say we are not part
of uh this military alliance we're not
part of that military alliance and so
there's nothing wrong with it but you
know nato is simply absolutely refusing
to acknowledge this and i think that
that's kind of why
we've got ourselves into this mess
because nato has just gone on expanding
and sooner or later russia was going to
say enough already and we're going to
we're going to do something about this
you know glenn again i want to go back
to something i said in the first part of
the program here is that there's this
seems to be we hear this mantra from
stoltenberg we're just
nato is just a dependent
alliance and say over and over and over
again as if it's on speed dial or
something but
if you look what's coming out of
european capital something like you know
going to the nuclear option throwing
russia out of the swiss system you know
that's easy for somebody in washington
you know in a think tank suburb you know
with air conditioning but you know the
germans are going to say well how are we
going to how is russia going to sell his
uh energy i mean your
european union countries you know they
import a third of their energy from
russia and it's good only going to grow
i mean throw them out of the swiss
system then how do you pay i mean is
anybody in washington thinking like this
because it seems that you know as george
and you both pointed out on this program
here is that even as so-called
negotiations are going on uh u.s
senators are showing up and kev says
sanctions sanctions sanction i mean do
they understand the gravity of all this
because it seems to me that nato is
desperate if it can't get its way every
single time then it's kind of a broken
system and no one will take it seriously
and i think they're very worried about
that go ahead glenn
well that is the purpose of nato i mean
when during the cold war nato was seen
as a necessity to balance the soviet
union after the cold war the purpose of
nato was collective hegemony so you join
it and
you know we we unilaterally make the
decisions now obviously um
then the main problem they're having now
is uh uh you know it was first of all
keeping this grouping together because
um america kind of suggesting you know
willing to fight the russians down to
the last european and you know it does
obviously the europeans are getting some
of some cold feet here because uh just
quickly a little bit back at what um uh
what george said as well a lot of what
has been able to keep the cohesion
between nato is strategic ambiguity i
mean already in the 90s you know the
americans could go to the french and
germans saying listen nato we're just
going to have nato as a democratic club
you know values it's not anti-russian
and then you have to go to the polls
going yeah of course we're here to
balance the russians and you know so you
can't be too explicit because these are
all contradictory positions so this is
the strategic ambiguity you don't and
this is why the russians want to go from
this very ambiguous to the specific and
uh and and that's why also they they
don't want to go down this route either
but uh
but the same as this threat to to nato
obviously you know the good possibility
of nato war against russia is a
possibility but it doesn't have to be
either or uh countries pursue what's
called escalation dominance which means
if
the u.s dominates on the long russian
borders they can essentially dictate
everything to the russians and knowing
that the americans can bring tensions up
or down that will and there's nothing
russia can do under those conditions
russia would always have to capitulate
and this is again this is what uh
collective hegemon is after so to say
that nato can't be a threat i mean it's
just again they can repeat this until it
sounds like makes sense but it doesn't
and yeah just lastly on this cutting
rush from swift and you know this
full-out economic war against
against
russia obviously this is going to hit
back on the europeans very hard i mean
russia spent at least the past eight
years making its economy sanctions proof
and it's getting
very close to having its fully proof i
mean they they have a diversified their
economy their financial instruments and
if
if they would cut russia off swift then
obviously this will bring a lot of pain
to european economies um but also the
question then becomes for example for
the germans how would we actually buy
gas from the russians maybe some
mechanisms can be set up but you don't
know how the russians will react if you
declare full-out economic war on them
you know they might have a counter
sanction they might have something up
their sleeve so they don't want to go
down this route so at the moment part of
the the us effort of enhancing his
negotiations tactics means this is
actually in qatar now talking to him
listen can you supply some more lng to
the europeans so because if they feel
more secure in the energy then we can
you know
then we can keep this anti-russian
alliance together they will be more they
will be a bit bolder to go after russia
so it's just it's um
they're having a huge problem because
they can't keep the solidarity together
the the possibility of having the
strategic ambiguity it's not working and
overall it's just uh the whole
thing seems to be melting down i mean at
the same time the british and americans
saying we we are standing united against
russia you have macron saying listen we
have to reimagine european security we
can't go on like this and you know also
the germans showing some understanding
for for the russian position
again it's not absurd this idea that
russia has security interests
shockingly and nato can be a threat yeah
i mean george the the the what makes it
so bizarre for me is that
from the official nato line as you know
russia russia is a a hostile aggressive
nation but
nato's even even nato's behavior in
approach towards russia engenders as a
mistrust and um um hostility i mean
they're generating it because as as
glenn just said i mean they want to go
down the sanction route you want to do
these these swift um pulling russia out
of the swift system well these are this
this is akin to war i mean it's
certainly economic war i mean
russia would be justified in reacting um
and and and in in an equally hostile way
i mean how how how does that create
pan-european security i mean it's it's
like it's begging a conflict because
there's the sense because of the nato
world view is that they are always right
and only their security matters and so
why should russia care i mean you can
have we've had talks for 30 years
they've
engendered nothing i mean there could be
a very serious russian reaction are they
taking that into account
i think that's an excellent point
because um you know
everything that nato has done
is very much uh
it can be seen to be part of containment
and enclosure and against russia and an
attempt to uh diminish and eliminate
russian power and influence in the world
i mean that that's what they you know
they've scooped up all of the members of
the warsaw back they have now scooped up
uh
former soviet republics they've
indicated that they have in every
intention of scooping up more uh soviet
republics this goes together with
extraordinarily belligerent rhetoric
coming from uh
the western capitals coming from the
nato secretary general i mean the way
they talk about russia as a kind of
monstrous evil uh place that you know we
we have to uh unite against and so
from the russian perspective i think
it's very reasonable to say well what
are they after they are after um
eliminating us eliminating us as any
kind of a force in the world it's not
dissimilar from what napoleon tried to
do it's not the symbol of what from what
hitler tried to do that is uh you know
that's the situation and we had better
move now
before in a decade it could just be too
late i mean they will just simply go
surrounded us with hostile
uh satellite states of uh nato and uh
it's hard to see you know how any any
kind of leadership uh in russia would
react in any other way you're using your
analogy there your parallels i mean
then it would be the breakup of russia
that would be the next that's the next
step absolutely would be the next step
yeah i mean and look they tried this in
the 90s um and there's no question i
mean would that if you know once once uh
russia is surrounded by these nato
satellite states lo and behold we're
going to find all kinds of um
irredentist movements uh inside russia
we're going to inside they find various
islamist independence movements um among
all the various um uh
you know these uh
autonomous republics within the russian
federation that would be the next step
would be to just you know step by step
to break russia up that was always
always been the agenda and so
you know how else could uh russia
respond other than this we're saying
look we've had enough you can either
discuss this now
in a in a proper way work out some
mutually acceptable framework or we're
just going to have to take uh steps uh
you know to ensure our security but what
you've been doing cannot go on and just
simply fobbing us off with well there
are no immediate plans to bring ukraine
into nato um
and so
okay we've run out of time here but i
think we're all in agreement uh talk is
just talk okay that's all the time we
have want to thank my guest in oslo and
budapest i want to thank our viewers for
watching us here at rt see you next time
and remember crosstalk rules